hey guys I'd like to thank you all for
commenting and voting on my last update
video although most people wanted to see
the double ninja star next which I now
have it tutorial for that you could find
by clicking on this link up here a lot
of people really wanted to see the
origami beating heart so because I love
all of my subscribers I'm going to show
you how to make this today so you can
get it out in time for Valentine's Day
you should also check out the origami
rose chocolate box tutorial by my friend
Mae which uses the origami roses from my
tutorial either that or you could try
the origami Valentine's Day tree this
probably won't score you any points
though the beating heart is really cool
and it actually beats when you press on
this little tab on the back here I think
that red or pink paper looks the nicest
but any color should work also the paper
does get a little bit thick towards the
end so if you do have origami paper you
can give that a try also once you have
the paper you're ready to begin the
first thing we need to do is to make the
printer paper into a square so you could
take the upper right corner here and
you're going to fold it across to the
left side so that the top edge is
aligned with the left side edge just
like that make a crease along the
outside and you'll see that I basically
creased it along this edge here so
crease it along that edge run your
fingernail against it a few times and
then you could just rip it along that
crease now you have a piece of square
paper and it has a diagonal fold going
this way so now that we've creased it
this way you're going to take the upper
left corner and fold it across to the
bottom right corner of the paper line up
all of the edges neatly and then you can
make a crease along the outside of the
paper here
so now if you open up the paper you'll
see you have an X in it now what you
want to do is to take the top edge of
the paper and fold it across to the
bottom edge once again line up the edges
neatly and then make a crease along the
top edge of the paper then you can open
up the paper once again now you'll see
we have a horizontal line so we're going
to take the left edge and fold it across
to the right edge again if you want to
turn your paper like this then you could
take the top edge and fold it across to
the bottom line up the edges neatly and
once again make a crease so if you open
up the paper you'll see you have an X
and you also have a cross in the paper
once again fold on the horizontal line
here and we're going to take these
corners and we're going to fold them
down to this bottom point here on the
paper so you just want to take the whole
piece of paper here fold it down like
this and make a crease on the outside do
the same for the left side take this
corner and fold it down to the bottom
here and it should be along this crease
here so just fold it down just like that
now we're going to take the model and
we're going to flip it over just like
this and you'll see in the middle of the
paper here we have a vertical line or
crease that divides the triangle in half
we're going to take both of these
outside edges of the triangle and fold
them directly on to that mid line just
like that what you don't want to fold
these back flaps in half so what you're
going to do is line up this outside edge
with the middle and let that flap pop
out from the back
so once you've done that take the edge
fold it in and let that flat pop out
then you could line up this edge with
the middle and then you could push down
all the way right here now you don't
want to crease it very hard because it
will leave a line on the front of the
heart so just push down on it and then
what you could do is lift up this flap
and then you can crease it more directly
on that edge there so it should look
something like this do the same with the
left side take the outside edge fold it
on to the midline and let that flap pop
out from the back line up this outside
edge with the middle and then you could
push down here
very gently then you could lift up this
flap and crease on this edge here so now
you should have something that looks
like this
now we could flip over the model again
and you'll see we have this pocket here
on the back what we're going to do is
we're going to take these edges here on
the bottom now and we're going to fold
them directly on to the midline so you
want to take this corner and fold it
inwards until this bottom edge is lined
up directly with the middle of the paper
like that fold it in and once it's lined
up in the middle make a crease on the
outside just like that
do the same with the left side so just
line up this edge with the middle
so you should have something that looks
like this this next step of making the
origami beating hardest probably the
trickiest one but I'm going to go
through it slowly and in a lot of detail
to make it easier to understand if
you've made the crane or the gift box
you'll see this is very similar to the
petal fold there's a few different ways
we can do it a little bit easier first
I'd like you to draw a line from this
corner of this diamond to the opposite
corner just as I've drawn there also you
want to make these edges here a little
bit sharper so just take your fingernail
and run it against those creases here to
make them very sharp now you can unfold
these two edges from the center and then
what we're going to do is we're going to
open up this pocket here and you want to
push on this line all the way across so
it should kind of crease on that line
there and what you're going to do is
you're going to take your finger and
you're going to push this edge of the
paper all the way up here just like this
and you'll see when we do that these
edges here will start to go inwards
towards the middle so you want to make
sure it's creasing on that line that you
drew push all the way up and you'll see
these edges will start to go inwards
then what you could do is you can fold
them along that same crease that I just
had you make sharp so just walk your
finger all the way up like this until
this edge of the paper is directly in
the middle and then crease it along this
edge here do the same with the left side
so just fold this inwards
I need to just pop it out like that and
make sure this edge is folding directly
in the middle of the paper like that
then you should have this little point
sticking up in the middle of the diamond
now what you could do is you could take
this point and fold it towards you
and then make a nice crease in the
middle of the model now you could lift
it up and we're going to take these two
corners here as you'll see they should
be separate and we're going to take the
point and fold it directly into the
middle here just want to take the point
and lift it up and fold it up so that
this edge folds on top of itself like
that and it should be right in the
middle of that point on the bottom fold
it like that and then make a crease
along the bottom of the paper here do
the same with the left side fold it up
make the point go in the middle and then
make a crease on the bottom so it should
look something like this now here's
where the paper gets a little bit thick
but what you're going to do is you're
going to take the corner here that we
now have and you're going to fold it
right at this point here where it meets
this edge so you want to just fold it
right in the middle of this line take it
fold it just like that and then make a
crease paper gets a little bit thick but
it's not going to make a big difference
in the end do the same with the other
side take it and just fold it like that
so you should have something that looks
just like this
now you can just kind of flip the model
over like this and what we're going to
do is we're just going to unfold this a
little bit and you'll see that we have
this corner of the paper that we folded
down and what we're going to do is
you'll see we made this little groove
here we're going to take this corner and
we're going to tuck it underneath this
little edge here so you want to take the
corner and you're going to take the
whole edge here and tuck it underneath
that edge of the paper there so that
this edge that's sticking out this
little mountain area is wrapped around
that edge
so just lift it up and just tuck it
underneath so it looks something like
that then you could just make a crease
along the top there do the same with the
left side take the corner and you're
going to tuck it underneath here then
all you need to do is to crease along
the top so you're pretty much almost
done with the heart all we need to do is
to fold these corners of the paper
inwards so just take the corner and fold
it in you want to fold it about halfway
point between this corner here and the
outside of the paper so fold it up to
right about there it doesn't have to be
exact it's really up to you just like
that and do the same at the left side
and there you go you have your origami
beating heart to make your heart beat
you're going to take your pointer and
middle finger and put it on top of this
tab here all the way up against the back
of the rose just like that and you're
going to take your thumb and put it on
the bottom of the tab there and then
you're going to squeeze sort of like
that so as you'll see my heart is not
beating properly and that's fine it
happens occasionally
and you want to take your finger and
just lift up here and round off this
edge do the same with the left side so
just squeeze it together and round off
this edge and then what you want to do
is to just take both halves of the heart
and fold them upwards and press in here
and there you go it should beat now I
hope that you found the tutorial for the
beating heart helpful and that you were
able to make it leave me a comment in
the comment section below and let me
know what you thought and I might
feature in my next video also if you did
like the video just be sure to click the
thumbs up or the like button down below
and
subscribe by clicking the silver button
above if you're not already thank you
very much for watching and I hope you
have a great Valentine's Day